so the new rule changes we focus so much  on it and this is a prime example with  james harden what he has done so well  the left off arm  tucking under and hooking bam out of bio  to seek contact and those were the calls  that he had mastered that he used to get  that now officials are not calling tries  to tuck under to create the contact and  the tricky part though james harden left  hannah so he's trying to get it back to  his shooting arm but those are the  motions that now officials going into  the season with the rule changes  are not calling and those were a lot of  the calls that james harden why he made  a living at the free-throw line through  his career averaging nearly nine free  throw attempts per game not getting  those calls but on the flip side of  things there's also as we've seen just  been a lot more contact overall that's  not being called on these drives to the  basket hardin has logged 31 minutes he's  now on the nets bench  bruce brown is in